[Music]
I've always had a bit of a crush on you
but then I find out that you love UFC
Ultimate Fighting Championship and I
thought oh my god a woman who loves UFC
is it true I'm absolutely obsessed yeah
completely completely and utterly
obsessed I originally was made aware of
it and introduced to the world a few of
Steve I'm one of my best friends who's
like a 5 foot 7 really hot very feminine
girly girly girly asian girl who turns
into a foam at the mouth monster
whenever she watches UFC and she
introduced me to it she came to my house
and she said oh we should watch it
there's a really great fight on and the
whole night was a blur except I woke up
the next morning with no voice and
really excited like I was just I don't
know what it's not under your
fingernails lease for calling yeah
so you see you really enjoy it you
scream and go crazy when you watch I do
I lose my voice I I go that nuts I get
really into it I mean I think it's it's
such an incredible sports these guys are
like incredible athletes and yet at the
same time I wonder what it says about me
that I like sweaty hot men bleeding all
over each other bashing each other in
the face but I guess you get with that
yeah I can live with this you're a
sociopath